حياتهم مع رفيده ياسين على العربيه
انا رفيده ياسين وهذه هي حياتهم على
العربيه
اليوم رحله الى عالم مختلف رحله تستحق
الشغف لانها ستركز على ملامح حياه عالم
مختلف حوله هل هو حقيقه ام خدعه هو عالم
قبيله تسدي اللي تم اكتشافه لاول مره في
اغسطس عام
1971 لما عرف العالم القبيله دي سمع عنها
عن طريق صوره لصبي صغير من ابناء القبيله
تصدر غلاف مجله ناشونال جيوغرافيك ولم تكن
تلك القبيله معروفه من قبل عند بقيه
العالم
افلام قبيله السداي بيعيشوا بطريقه بدائيه
تماما وكان الاكتشاف الاهم بالنسبه للبعثه
اللي ارسلتها المجله هو الطريق اللي
بيتعايش فيها افراد تلك القبيله وماذا
تقبلهم لوجود كائنات اخرى على سطح هذا
الكوكب الغريب انه قبيله تسداي عباره عن
مجموعه من الاشخاص زي اسره واحده لا يتعدى
عددا الثلاثين شخص وهم حوالي اشخاص
بيجلسوا في مكان واحد يتردد انهم موجودين
في تلك المنطقه من العصر الحجري بيعيشوا
وسطهاله من الغموض والبعد والعزال عن
العالم
القبيله دي بتعيش بعيد عن كل ما هو عصري
وده منذ مئات السنين بيقال انهم من كان
الاصليين للجزيره من دناو الفلبينيه وهي
قبيله كانت بتعيش على الصيد في اعتماد
الكلي على حياته اما لغه فبتختلف عن جميع
اللغات اللي بتتكلم بها القبائل المجاوره
لهم بيعتقد بعض علماء اللغه انه لغتهم
بتنقسم من لغات مانوبو واللغه دي كانت
موجوده منذ حوالي 200 سنه تقريبا
ابناء القبيله لم يتعرفوا كما يتردد على
وسائل التكنولوجيا نهائيا يعني بيعيشوا
حياه بسيطه تماما بعيده كل البعد عن كل
وسائل الحياه الموجوده الان يعني لا توجد
اسلحه لا يوجد نحت لا توجد ملابس ولا
منازل ولا حتى في اهتمام بالزراعه
انعزلوا عن العالم كله منذ العصر الحجري
وما بيعرف ولا صراعات عنف بيعيشوا في سلام
تام ووئام داخل مجتمعم الصغير مع بعضهم
البعض
العالم ده بيسكن داخل الكهوف وما بيخرج
منها الا للحصول على الطعام والشراب ثم
بيعود الى مخبا امراء اخرى ولم نمط حياته
البسيط والهادق داخل الكهف شعب تسداي او
قبيله سداي المكونه من اسره واحده اعتدوا
انهم يسكنوا داخل الكهوف وما بيخفوا
عوراتهم باستخدام الملابس بس يستخدم ورق
التوت حياته هادئه ونمط حياته بروتيني ولا
يتغير بس بيخشوا وصول الغرباء الى حياته
بعض علماء الانسانيات حول العالم راغبوا
في زياره تلك المنطقه اللي بيسكنها قبيله
لذلك الوقت من السبعينيات رئيس دوله
الفلبين حينها ماركوس رفض الطلب ده معللا
السبب بانه لا يريد ان تتلوث براءه هؤلاء
البشر بسبب بعض تجارب العلماء اللي كان
عندها تاثير سالب على المجتمعات وقام بعمل
مستعمره محدوده لهم مغلقه عشان يسكنها
واذا كان في نفس العام اللي تم اكتشافه
فيهم في عام
عدد قبيله تتساداي بتنتشر في القبيله
لعالم خاص بهم ومختلف من ابرز عادات
ومتقاليدهم عدم قتل الحيوانات لاكلها
لانهم بيظنوا ان الحيوانات
صديقه لهم ويجب الحفاظ على كل كائن الحي
يشاركم ذات المكان وذات نمط الحياه
لان الحيوانات اصدقائهم وبيحرص على ان
يكونوا معاهم في داخل الكهوف او حتى في
رحلهما الخارجيه للبحث عن طعام وشراب
شعب تسداي بيحصل على اللحوم عن طريق صيد
الاسماك فقط لانهم لا ياكلوا بيض الطيور
الموجوده معهم ولا يذبحون اي من الطيور او
حتى الحيوانات اللي بتعيش معهم في نفس
المكان المحيط
يعتقد افراد قبيله ساداي انه الحيوانات
الموجوده معهم كائنات صديقه تستحق الحياه
مثلهم تماما في سنه
1986 قام احد الصحفيين من سويسرا وهو زوال
ايتن بالتسلل المستعمره دي من غير ما ياخذ
تصريح وكانت المفاجاه بانه وجد جميع افراد
المستعمله من قبيله سداي يرتدوا ملابس
عصريه وبتناوله وارز وما بيجلسوا داخل
الكهوف المهجوره اللي اعتاد وعيش فيها
[موسيقى]
الكلام ده اثار حفيظه عدد كبير من
المستكشفين اللي كانوا بيتهموا الصحفي
اللي قام باول تقرير عنهم بانه يزور
تفاصيل حياتهم نظير الحصول على معلومات
غير حقيقيه
[موسيقى]
وانه حقيقه حياه قبيله سداي ليست كما تم
التعريف عليها لاول مره ومجموعه من
القبائل المحليه المعروفه وضع نظام
معيشتهم على نفس نظام حياه العصر الحجري
واذا كان تحت ضغط واسرار من السلطه وقيل
انه هؤلاء كانوا بيمثلوا امام العالم وان
الامر اذا كان خدعه وطلب منهم ذلك من قبل
احد المسؤولين مقابل اعطاء بعض النقود
والسجائر واللي استغل التمثيليه دي في جمع
الاموال من اجل الحفاظ على القبيله نقيه
ثم هرب بالتبرعات اللي حصل عليها بسبب
السمعه اللي اخذوها من هذه المعلومات وذهب
خارج البلاد
حتى الان هناك اختلاف على حقيقه واصول
وطبيعه حياه شعب جسدي ولكن هنالك بروفيسور
يدعى لورانس عاش اشهر مع هذه القبيله
بالاضافه الى بعض القبائل المجاوره في
محاوله منه للبحث عن الحقيقه واكتشاف اصول
هذه العوالم وحقيقته وفي منتصف التسعينيات
توصلت بروفيسور الى ان القبيله دي بالفعل
ربما كانت معزوله عن غيره كما قيل او كما
تردد عن روايتها الاولى وانهم في الحقيقه
ما يعرف كيفيه الزراعه ولغتهم كانت مختلفه
كما نمط حياته المعزول والمختلف عن غير من
المجتمعات والقبائل الاخرى المجاوره لهم
وقال ايضا هذا الباحث والمستكشف بانه لا
توجد خدعه وانه من تحدث عنهم في كل
كتاباته وتقاريره حاول ان يعكس امراه في
الحقيقه
العالم ده ابروفيسور لورانس كتب عنهم في
كتاب علم الاثار اللغويه وكان في فصل عن
تتبع لغه كساداي بروفيسور لورانس بيعتقد
انه كان بيوجد فرض اسمه السعيدي وهو من
يقوم بصنع تلك الكلمات الخاصه بلغه ووجد
10 من الاشخاص الاخرين استخدموا اللغه دي
في عصور مختلفه ومناطق ليست بعيده وان تلك
القبيله عباره عن مجموعه منفصله بتعيش في
الغابه وهم نادرا ما يكونوا على صله
بغيرهم او بمن حولهم من المجموعات الاخرى
السكنيه بس ثقافتهم لم تكن نفس ثقافه
العصر الحجري وبرهم من اكتشاف الكذبه دي
الا انه كان يوجد فعل غريب وقوي
قبل من صدقوا بوجود هذه القبيله وقاموا
بتكذيب صاحب التقرير الصحفي الاول اللي
تكلم عن القبيله بتفاصيل مختلفه
وبغض النظر عن الخلاف بشان حقيقه خلفيات
قبيله سداي الا انهم مجموعه من الناس
اعداد محدوده خلقين لنفسهم عالم خاص ولا
ينتظر من احد الاقتراب منه ولا حتى عندهم
رغبه في الاختلاط بغيره من الغرباء لانهم
بيعتقدوا في الاحتكاك بالعالم الخارجي انه
قد يعود عليهم بالشرق والدمار وما عندهم
مطلب ابرز من انه العالم الخارجي يترككم
في حالهم على بساطتهم وهدوء دون اي محاوله
لكسر هذه الهاله لاكتشاف ما وراء ما
يخفونه من معلومات ببساطه لان هذه هي
حياتهم
[موسيقى]